I've never learned to type with 10
fingers
how many do you use
well I choose all 10 of them but not
very well
but I I never I never took a type in
class and I never sort of corrected that
so the first time I I seriously learned
I I had to learn the layout of a QWERTY
two keyboard
was actually in college in my first
programming classes
where we used Punch Cards
and so
with my two fingers I sort of pecked out
my code
watch anyone
give you a little coding demonstration
they'll have to produce like four lines
of code
and now see how many times they use the
backspace key yeah because they made a
mistake and and
some people especially when when someone
else is looking
will will backspace over 20 30 40
characters to fix a typo earlier in a
line if you're
if you're slightly more experienced of
course you use your arrow buttons to go
or your mouse to but the mouse is
usually slower than than the arrows
but a lot of people when they type a 20
character word which is not unusual and
they realize they made us made a mistake
at the start of the word the backspace
over the whole thing
and then retype it and sometimes it
takes three four times to get it right
so
I don't know what your definition of bug
is arguably mistyping a word and then
correcting it immediately is not a bug
on the other hand you you already
do sort of lose time and every once in a
while there's sort of a typo that you
don't get in that process
and now you've you've you've typed like
10 lines of code
uh and some were in the middle of it you
don't know where yet is a typo or maybe
a thinko where you you forgot that you
had to initialize a variable or
something but those are two different
things and I would say yes you have to
actually run the code to discover that
typo but forgetting to initialize a
variable is a fundamentally different
thing because that thing can go
undiscovered uh that depends on the
language in Python it will not right and
it's sort of modern compilers are
usually pretty good at catching that
even
even foresee so for that specific thing
but actually deeper
it might there might be another variable
that has initialized but logically
speaking the one you meant related yep
it's like name the same but it's a
different thing and you forgot to
initialize uh whatever some counter or
some some basic variable they're using I
can tell that you've coded yes by the
way I should mention that I use the
Kinesis keyboard
which has the backspace under the thumb
and one of the biggest reasons I use
that keyboard is because you realize in
order to use the backspace on a usual
keyboard you have to stretch your pinky
out
and like the the for most normal
keyboards the Backspaces under the pinky
and so I don't know if people realize
the pain they go through in their life
because of the backspace keep being so
far away so with the Kinesis it's right
under the thumb so you don't have to
actually move your hands the backspace
and the delivery what do you do if
you're ever not with your own keyboard
and you have to use someone else's PC
keyboard that has a standard layout so
first of all it turns out that you can
actually go your whole life always
having the keyboard
with you so this well except for that
that little tablet that you're using so
we're note taking right now right uh
yeah so it's very inefficient
note-taking but I'm not I'm just looking
stuff up but in most cases I would be
actually using the keyboard here right
now I just don't anticipate you have to
calculate how much typing do you
anticipate if I anticipate quite a bit
then I'll just I have a keyboard and the
same same with I mean
the embarrassing
of accepted being the weirdo that I am
but you know when I go on an airplane
and I anticipate to do programming or a
lot of typing I will have a laptop that
will put pull out a Kinesis keyboard in
addition to the laptop and it's just who
I am you have to you have to accept who
you are
um but also it's a you know for a lot of
people
for me certainly there's a comfort space
where there's a certain kind of setups
that are maximized productivity
and
um it's like some people have a warm
blanket that they like when they watch a
movie I like the Kinesis keyboard takes
me to uh a place of focus and I still
mostly I I'm trying to make sure I use
the state of the art IDs for everything
but my comfort place just like the
Kinesis keyboard is still emacs
so
I still use that I still I mean that's
one of some of the debates I have with
myself about everything from a
technology perspective
is how much to hold on to the tools
you're comfortable with versus how much
to invest in using modern tools and the
signal that the communities provide you
with is the noisy one because a lot of
people year to year get excited about
new tools and you have to make a
prediction are these tools defining a
new generation or something that will
transform programming or is this just a
fad that will pass